oui et des choses ont vraiment changé
parce que d'une part il ya eu de moins
en moins voire quasiment plus
d'utilisation de nouvelles mines donc
c'est une chose il ya moins de
territoire de nouveaux territoires
pollués il ya eu beaucoup plus de
déminage
donc il ya eu des nouveaux territoires
qui ont été libérés de la menace est
donc les gens ont pu recommencer à
cultiver des gens ont pu recommencer à
construire à à faire des routes qui
passait à travers ces terrains là il ya
eu une stigmatisation en fait des états
qui ne signait pas se traiter en leur
disant sûr sur la scène internationale
que c'était c'était une honte tout
simplement de ne pas rejoindre le traité
d'interdiction des mines ans personnes
dont de plus en plus d'états ont rejoint
et rejoint de traiter ces tâtonnements
une signature heureusement notre éthique
et s'engager à aider les communautés
s'est engagé à fournir les financements
nécessaires pour dépolluer pour assister
les victimes
et puis le meilleur exemple de ces vingt
années c'est en fait la diminution du
nombre de victimes
au début on parlait d'une victime toutes
les 20 minutes
donc il ya 20 ans il ya 25 ans les
chiffres faisait état que la moyenne de
victimes qui étaient toutes les 20
minutes
aujourd'hui on est à plusieurs heures
par jour c'est encore énorme mais on
s'est quand même aussi une augmentation
et une amélioration très importante de
la bête en fait du nombre de victimes
jérôme bobin qu'est-ce qu'on peut
atteindre donc pour les prochaines 21 au
niveau du travail qui est fait à travers
le monde par un handicap international
et les instances étatiques dix ans pour
les prochains pain alors pour les
prochaines vingt 20 années en fait j'en
veux dire il faut pas attendre 20 ans au
coeur des victimes et gérant qui vivent
dans les zones qui restent collés non on
parle 20 ans devrait en fait il faut il
faut que ce soit beaucoup plus rapide et
l'engagement international
il est plus à l'horizon de 2025 donc on
parle dans moins de dix ans en moins de
dix ans l'objectif de la communauté
internationale des acteurs humanitaires
fait que l'entente du monde soit
débarrassée des mines antipersonnel ça
peut paraître encore un peu illusoire
mais en fait c'est possible si tout le
monde est tout le monde a finalement les
états en fait donne les moyens et se
donne les moyens de dépolluer des
territoires qui sont 1 qui sont encore
touchées comme la colombie
comme le laos le cambodge comme graves
comme la libye encore des territoires
qui ont des mines antipersonnel mais on
sait pour la plupart ont fait ou a dit
on et il faut donc il faut donc juste
les moyens de travailler a enlevé cette
menace tapie l'accompagner mais
wiedeking